Attorney General Jeff Sessions is in
Sacramento this morning where he's
expected to formally unveil a lawsuit
against California's sanctuary policies
Justice Department lawyers filed the
suit last night they want a federal
court to stop California from
implementing three state laws that
protect protect undocumented immigrants
the DOJ says the state is intentionally
interfering with federal immigration
activities Paula Reed is outside the
Justice Department in Washington Paula
good morning good morning this lawsuit
is just the latest development and it's
escalating feud between the Trump
administration and states like
California and other sanctuary cities
now this lawsuit alleges that the state
of California is violating the US
Constitution by passing state laws that
preempt federal laws the governor of
california pushed back against the
lawsuit last night tweeting jeff
Sessions has come to California to
further divide and polarize America
Jeff these political stunts may be the
norm in Washington but they don't work
here
sad although it's important to note that
the state of California has sued the
Trump administration numerous times the
Trump administration has been previously
threatened to withhold money or even
federal agents from California unless
the sanctuary cities agree to identify
and hold suspected undocumented
immigrants now the Justice Department is
also considering charging state
officials who interfere with federal
immigration activities now Justice
Department officials tell me they are
also reviewing other sanctuary cities
across the country and they have not
ruled out the possibility of additional
lawsuits against those jurisdictions
Noora all right Paula thank you so much